The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or give
you additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So
again, before we start,
there is a survey online
if you haven't done so.
I would guess at least
one of you has not.
Some of you have entered their
answers and their thoughts,
and I really appreciate this.
It's actually very helpful.
So it seems that the
course is going fairly well
from what I've read so far.
So if you don't think
this is the case,
please enter your
opinion and tell us
how we can make it better.
One of the things
that was said is
that I speak too fast,
which is absolutely true.
I just can't help it.
I get so excited, but I
will really do my best.
I will try to.
I think I always start OK.
I just end not so well.
So last time we talked about
this chi squared distribution,
which is just another
distribution that's
so common that it
deserves its own name.
And this is
something that arises
when we sum the squares of
independent standard Gaussian
random variables.
And in particular,
why is that relevant?
It's because if I look
at the sample variance,
then it is a chi
square distribution,
and the parameter
that shows up is also
known as the degrees of
freedom, is the number
of observations of minus one.
And so as I said,
this chi squared
distribution has an explicit
probability density function,
and I tried to draw it.
And one of the comments was
also about my handwriting,
so I will actually not rely
on it for detailed things.
So this is what the chi squared
with one degree of freedom
would look like.
And really, what this is is just
the distribution of the square
of a standard Gaussian.
I'm summing only one,
so that's what it is.
Then when I go to 2,
this is what it is--
3, 4, 5, 6, and 10.
And as I move, you
can see this thing
is becoming flatter and flatter,
and it's pushing to the right.
And that's because I'm
summing more and more squares,
and in expectation we
just get one every time.
So it really means that the
mass is moving to infinity.
In particular, a chi
squared distribution
with n degrees of freedom
is going to infinity
as n goes to infinity.
Another distribution
that I asked
you to think about--
anybody looked around
about the student
t-distribution, what
the history of this thing was?
So I'll tell you a little bit.
I understand if you
didn't have time.
So the t-distribution is
another common distribution
that is so common
that it will be used
and will have its table
of quintiles that are
drawn at the back of the book.
Now, remember, when I
mentioned the Gaussian, I said,
well, there are several
values for alpha
that we're interested in.
And so I wanted to draw
a table for the Gaussian.
We had something that
looked like this,
and I said, well, q alpha
over 2 to get alpha over 2
to the right of this number.
And we said that there is
a table for this things,
for common values of theta.
Well, if you try to envision
what this table will look like,
it's actually a
pretty sad table,
because it's basically
one list of numbers.
Why would I call it a table?
Because all I need
to tell you is
something that looks like this.
If I tell you this is alpha
and this is q alpha over 2
and then I say, OK,
basically the three alphas
that I told you I care about are
something like 1%, 5%, and 10%,
then my table will just
give me q alpha over 2.
So that's alpha, and
that's q alpha over 2.
And that's going
to tell me that--
I don't remember this
one, but this guy is 1.96.
This guy is something like 2.45.
I think this one
is like 1.65 maybe.
And maybe you can
be a little finer,
but it's not going
to be an entire page
at the back of the book.
And the reason is
because I only need
to draw these things
for d1 standard Gaussian
when the parameters
are 0 for the mean
and 1 for the variance.
Now, if I'm actually doing
this for the the chi squared,
I basically have to give
you one table per values
of the degrees of freedom,
because those things
are different.
There is no way I can take--
for Gaussian's, if you
give me a different mean,
I can substract it and make it
back to be a standard Gaussian.
For the chi squared,
there is no such thing.
There is no thing
that just takes
the chi squared with d
degrees of freedom, nd,
and turns it into,
say, a chi square
with one degree of freedom.
This just does not happen.
So the word is standardized.
Make it a standard chi squared.
There is no such thing
as standard chi squared.
So what it means
is that I'm going
to need one row like that
for each value of the number
of degrees of freedom.
So that will certainly fill a
page at the back of a book--
maybe even more.
I need one per sample size.
So if I want to go from
simple size 1 to 1,000,
I need 1,000 rows.
So now the student
distribution is
one that arises where it looks
very much like the Gaussian
distribution, and there's a
very simple reason for that, is
that I take a standard Gaussian
and I divide it by something.
That's how I get the student.
What do I divide it with?
Well, I take an
independent chi square--
I'm going to call it v--
and I want it to be
independent from z.
And I'm going to divide
z by root v over d.
So I start with a chi squared v.
So this guy is chi squared d.
I start with z, which is n 0, 1.
I'm going to assume that
those guys are independent.
In my t-distribution,
I'm going to write
a T. Capital T is z divided by
the square root of v over d.
Why would I want to do this?
Well, because this
is exactly what
happens when a divide not by
the true variance, a Gaussian,
but by its empirical variance.
So let's see why in a second.
So I know that if you give
me some random variable--
let's call it x, which
is N mu sigma squared--
then I can do this.
x minus mu divided by sigma.
I'm going to call this thing
z, because this thing actually
has some standard
Gaussian distribution.
I have standardized
x into something
that I can read the quintiles
at the back of the book.
So that's this process
that I want to do.
Now, to be able to do this,
I need to know what mu is,
and I need to know
what sigma is.
Otherwise I'm not going to be
able to make this operation.
mu I can sort of get away
with, because remember,
when we're doing
confidence intervals
we're actually solving for mu.
So it was good
that mu was there.
When we're doing
hypothesis testing,
we're actually plugging in here
the mu that shows up in h0.
So that was good.
We had this thing.
Think of mu as being
p, for example.
But this guy here, we don't
necessarily know what it is.
I just had to tell you for
the entire first chapter,
assume you have Gaussian
random variables
and that you know
what the variance is.
And the reason why
I said assume you
know it-- and I said
sometimes you can read it
on the side of the box of
measuring equipment in the lab.
That was just the
way I justified it,
but the real reason why I did
this is because I would not
be able to perform this
operation if I actually did not
know what sigma was.
But from data, we know that
we can form this estimator
Sn, which is 1 over n,
sum from i equals 1 to n
of Xi, minus X bar squared.
And this thing is approximately
equal to sigma squared.
That's the sample
variance, and it's actually
a good estimator just by the
law of large number, actually.
This thing, by the law of large
number, as n goes to infinity--
well, let's say
it in probability
goes to sigma squared by
the law of large number.
So it's a consistent
estimator of sigma squared.
So now, what I
want to do is to be
able to use this estimator
rather than using sigma.
And the way I'm
going to do it is
I'm going to say, OK,
what I want to form
is x minus mu divided
by Sn this time.
I don't know what the
distribution of this guy is.
Sorry, it's square root of Sn.
This is sigma squared.
So this is what I would take.
And I could think
of Slutsky, maybe,
something like this that would
tell me, well, just use that
and pretend it's a Gaussian.
And we'll see how
actually it's sort
of valid to do that,
because Slutsky tells us
it is valid to do that.
But what we can
also do is to say,
well, this is actually equal to
x minus mu, divided by sigma,
which I knew what the
distribution of this guy is.
And then what I'm going to
do is I'm going to just--
well, I'm going to cancel this
effect, sigma over square root
Sn.
So I didn't change anything.
I just put the sigma here.
So now what I know what I
know is that this is some z,
and it has some standard
Gaussian distribution.
What is this guy?
Well, I know that Sn--
we wrote this here.
Maybe I shouldn't have
put those pictures,
because now I keep on
skipping before and after.
We know that Sn times n
divided by sigma squared
is actually chi
squared n minus 1.
So what do I have here?
I have that chi squared--
so here I have something that
looks like 1 over square root
of Sn divided by sigma squared.
This is what this guy is if
I just do some more writing.
And maybe I actually want to
make my life a little easier.
I'm actually going
to plug in my n here,
and so I'm going to have to
multiply by square root of n
here.
Everybody's with me?
So now what I end up
with is something that
looks like this, where I have--
here I started with x.
I should really start
with Xn bar minus mu times
square root of n.
That's what the central
limit theorem would tell me.
I need to work with the
average rather than just one
observation.
So if I start with this, then
I pick up a square root of n
here.
So if I had the sigma
here, I would know
that this thing is actually--
Xn bar minus mu divided by
sigma times the square root of n
would be a standard Gaussian.
So if I put Xn
bar here, I really
need to put this thing that
goes around the Xn bar.
That's just my
central limit theorem
that says if I average, then my
variance has shrunk by a factor
1 over n.
Now, I can still do this.
That was still fine.
And now I said that this
thing is basically this guy.
So what I know is
that this thing
is a chi squared with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom,
so this guy here is
chi squared with n
minus 1 degrees of freedom.
Let me call this thing v in the
spirit of what was used there
and in the spirit of
what is written here.
So this guy was called v,
so I'm going to call this v.
So what I can write is
that square root of n Xn
bar minus mu divided
by square root of Sn
is equal to z times
square root of n
divided by square root of
v. Everybody's with me here?
Which I can rewrite as z times
square root of v divided by n
And if you look at what the
definition of this thing is,
I'm almost there.
What is the only thing
that's wrong here?
This is a student
distribution, right?
So there's two things.
The first one was that
they should be independent,
and they actually
are independent.
That's what Cochran's
theorem tells me,
and you just have to
count on me for this.
I told you already that Sn
was independent of Xn bar.
So those two guys
are independent,
which implies that the
numerator and denominator here
are independent.
That's what Cochran's
theorem tells us.
But is this exactly
what I should
be seeing if I wanted to
have my sample variance, if I
want to have to write this?
Is this actually the definition
of a student distribution?
Yes?
No.
So we see z divided by
square root of v over d.
That looks pretty much
like it, except there's
a small discrepancy.
What is the discrepancy?
There's just the square
root of n minus 1 thing.
So here, v has n minus
1 degrees of freedom.
And in the definition, if the
v has d degrees of freedom,
I divide it by d, not by d minus
1 or not by d plus 1, actually,
in this case.
So I have this extra thing.
Well, there's two ways
I can address this.
The first one is
by saying, well,
this is actually equal
to z over square root
of v divided by n minus
1 times square root of n
over n minus 1.
I can always do that and
say for n large enough
this thing is actually
going to be pretty small,
or I can take account for it.
Or for any n you give me,
I can compute this number.
And so rather than
having a t-distribution,
I'm going to have a
t-distribution time
this deterministic
number, which is just
a function of my
number of observations.
But what I actually
want to do instead
is probably use a slightly
different normalization,
which is just to say, well,
why do I have to define Sn--
where was my Sn?
Yeah, why do I have to define
Sn tend to be divided by n?
Actually, this is
a biased estimator,
and if I wanted to be
unbiased, I can actually just
put an n minus 1 here.
You can check that.
You can expend this thing
and compute the expectation.
You will see that it's
actually not sigma squared,
but n over n minus
1 sigma squared.
So you can actually
just make it unbiased.
Let's call this
guy tilde, and then
when I put this tilde here what
I actually get is s tilde here
and s tilde here.
I need actually to
have n minus 1 here
to have this s tilde be a
chi squared distribution.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] defined
this way so that you--
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So basically,
this is what the story did.
So the story was, well,
rather than using always
the central limit theorem
and just pretending
that my Sn is actually
the true sigma squared,
since this is something
I'm going to do a lot,
I might as well just
compute the distribution,
like the quintiles for this
particular distribution,
which clearly does not depend
on any unknown parameter.
d is the only parameter
that shows up here,
and it's completely
characterized
by the number of
observations that you have,
which you definitely know.
And so people said, let's just
be slightly more accurate.
And in a second, I'll show you
how the distribution of the T--
so we know that if the
sample size is large enough,
this should not have any
difference with the Gaussian
distribution.
I mean, those two
things should be
the same because we've
actually not paid
attention to this discrepancy by
using empirical variance rather
than true so far.
And so we'll see what
the difference is,
and this difference actually
manifests itself only
in small sample sizes.
So those are things
that matter mostly
if you have less than,
say, 50 observations.
Then you might want to
be slightly more precise
and use t-distribution
rather than Gaussian.
So this is just a matter of
being slightly more precise.
If you have more
than 50 observations,
just drop everything
and just pretend
that this is the true one.
Any other questions?
So now I have this
thing, and so I'm
on my way to changing this guy.
So here now, I have not
root n but root n minus 1.
So I have a z.
So this guy here is S. Yet
Where did I get my root
n from in the first place?
Yeah, because I wanted this guy.
And so now what I am
left with is Xn minus mu
divided by Sn tilde, which
is the new one, which is now
indeed of the form z v
root n minus 1, which now I
can write it as z v minus 1.
And so now I have
exactly what I want,
and so this guy is n 0, 1.
And this guy is chi squared with
n minus 1 degrees of freedom.
And so now I'm back
to what I want.
So rather than using Sn to be
the empirical variance where
I just divide my normatizations
by n, if I use n minus 1,
I'm perfect.
Of course, I can still use
n and do this multiplying
by root n minus 1
over n at the end.
But that just doesn't
make as much sense.
Everybody's fine with what
this T n distribution is doing
and why this last
line is correct?
So that's just
basically because it's
been defined so that this
is actually happening.
That was your question, and
that's really what happened.
So what is this
student t-distribution?
Where does the name come from?
Well, it does not come from
Mr. T. And if you know who Mr.
T was-- you're probably
too young for that--
he was our hero in the 80s.
And it comes from this guy.
His name is Sean
William Gosset--
1908.
So that was back in the day.
And this guy actually worked
at the Guinness Brewery
in Dublin, Ireland.
And Mr. Guinness back then
was a bit of a fascist,
and he didn't want him to
actually publish papers.
And so what he had to do is
to use a fake name to do that.
And he was not very creative,
and he used a name "student."
Because I guess he
was a student of life.
And so here's the guy, actually.
So back in 1908,
it was actually not
difficult to put your
name or your pen name
on a distribution.
So what does this
thing look like?
How does it compare to the
standard normal distribution?
You think it's going to have
heavier or lighter tails
compared to the
standard distribution,
the Gaussian distribution?
Yeah, because they have extra
uncertainty in the denominator,
so it's actually going to make
things wiggle a little wider.
So let's start with
a reference, which
is the standard
normal distribution.
So that's my usual
bell-shaped curve.
And this is actually
the t-distribution
with 50 degrees of freedom.
So right now, that's probably
where you should just
stand up and leave,
because you're like,
why are we wasting our time?
Those are actually pretty much
the same thing, and it is true.
If you have 50 observations,
both the central limit
theorem-- so here one of the
things that you need to know
is that if I want to talk about
t-distribution for, say, eight
observations, I need those
observations to be Gaussian
for real.
There's no central
limit theorem happening
at eight observations.
But really, what
this is telling me
is not that the central
limit theorem kicks in.
It's telling me what are the
asymptotics that kick in?
The law of large number, right?
This is exactly this guy.
That's here.
When I write this statement,
what this picture is really
telling us is that for n is
equal to 50, I'm at the limit
already almost.
There's virtually no
difference between using
the left-hand side or
using sigma squared.
And now I start reducing.
40, I'm still pretty good.
We can start seeing that
this thing is actually
losing some mass
on top, and that's
because it's actually
pushing it to the left
and to the right in the tails.
And then we keep going,
keep going, keep going.
So that's at 10.
When you're at 10, there's
not much of a difference.
And so you can start
seeing difference
when you're at
five, for example.
You can see the
tails become heavier.
And the effect of this is
that when I'm going to build,
for example, a confidence
interval to put the same amount
of mass to the right
of some number--
let's say I'm going to look
at this q alpha over 2--
I'm going to have to
go much farther, which
is going to result in much
wider confidence intervals
to 4, 3, 2, 1.
So that's the t1.
Obviously that's the worst.
And if you ever use
the t1 distribution,
please ask yourself, why in the
world are you doing statistics
based on one observation?
But that's basically what it is.
So now that we have
this t-distribution,
we can define a more
sophisticated test
than just take your
favorite estimator
and see if it's far from the
value you're currently testing.
That was our rationale
to build a test before.
And the first test
that's non-trivial
is a test that exploits the
fact that the maximum likelihood
estimator, under some
technical condition,
has a limit distribution
which is Gaussian with mean 0
when properly centered and
a covariance matrix given
by the Fisher
information matrix.
Remember this Fisher
information matrix?
And so this is the
setup that we have.
So we have, again, an i.i.d.
sample.
Now I'm going to assume that I
have a d-dimensional parameter
space, theta.
And that's why I talk about
Fisher information matrix--
and not just Fisher information.
It's a number.
And I'm going to
consider two hypotheses.
So you're going to have h0,
theta is equal to theta 0.
h1, theta is not
equal to theta 0.
And this is basically
what we thought
when we said, are we testing
if a coin is fair or unfair.
So fair was p equals 1/2, and
fair was p different from 1/2.
And here I'm just making
my life a bit easier.
So now, I have this
maximum likelihood estimate
that I can construct.
Because let's say I
know what p theta is,
and so I can build a maximum
likelihood estimator.
And I'm going to assume that
these technical conditions that
ensure that this maximum
likelihood properly
standardized converges to some
Gaussian are actually satisfy,
and so this thing
is actually true.
So the theorem, the
way I stated it--
if you're a little puzzled,
this is not the way I stated it.
And the first time, the way we
stated it was that theta hat
mle minus theta
not-- so here I'm
going to place myself
under the null hypothesis,
so here I'm going
to say under h0.
And honestly, if you have
any exercise on tests,
that's the way that
it should start.
What is the
distribution under h0?
Because otherwise you don't
know what this guy should be.
So you have this,
and what we showed
is that this thing was going
in distribution as n goes
to infinity to some
normal with mean 0
and covariance matrix,
which was i of theta,
which was here for
the true parameter.
But here I'm under
h0, so there's
only one true parameter,
which is theta 0.
This was our limiting
central limit theorem for--
I mean, it's not really
central limited theorem;
limited theorem for the
maximum likelihood estimator.
Everybody remembers that part?
The line before said, under
technical conditions, I guess.
So now, it's not really
stated in the same way.
If you look at
what's on the slide,
here I don't have the
Fisher information matrix,
but I really have
the identity of rd.
If I have a random
variable x, which
has some covariance
matrix sigma,
how do I turn this thing
into something that
has covariance matrix identity?
So if this was a sigma squared,
well, the thing I would do
would be divide by
sigma, and then I
would have a 1,
which is also known
as the identity matrix of r1.
Now, what is this?
This was root of sigma squared.
So what I'm looking
for is the equivalent
of taking sigma and dividing
by the square root of sigma,
which--
obviously those are matrices--
I'm certainly not allowed to do.
And so what I'm going
to do is I'm actually
going to do the following.
Sigma 1 over root
of sigma squared
can be written as sigma
to the negative 1/2.
And this is actually
the same thing here.
So I'm going to write it as
sigma to the negative 1/2,
and now this guy is
actually well-defined.
So this is a positive
symmetric matrix,
and you can actually
define the square root
by just taking the square
root of its eigenvalues,
for example.
And so you get sigma 1/2
equals and follows n0 identity.
And in general, I'm
going to see something
that looks like sigma
1/2 negative 1/2 sigma
sigma negative 1/2.
And I have minus 1/2
plus 1 minus 1/2.
This whole thing collapses to 0,
and it's actually the identity.
So that's the actual rule.
So if you're not familiar, this
is basic multivariate Gaussian
distribution computations.
Take a look at it.
If you feel like you
don't need to look at it
but you the basic maneuver,
it's fine as well.
We're not going to go
much deeper into that,
but those are part
of the thing that
are sort of standard
manipulations
about standard Gaussian vectors.
Because obviously,
standard Gaussian vectors
arise from this theorem a lot.
So now I pre-multiplied my
sigma to minus minus 1/2.
Now of course, I'm doing all
of this in the asymptotics,
and so I have this effect.
So if I pre-multiply
everything by sigma to the 1/2,
sigma being the Fisher
information matrix at theta 0,
then this is actually equivalent
to saying that square root
of n--
so now i of theta now
plays the role of sigma--
times theta hat mle minus
theta not goes in distribution
as n goes to infinity to some
multivariate standard Gaussian
and 0 identity of rd.
And here, to make
sure that we're
talking about a
multivariate distribution,
I can put a d here--
so just so we know we're
talking about the multivariate,
though it's pretty
clear from the context,
since the covariance matrix
is actually a matrix and not
a number.
Michael?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Oh, yeah.
Right.
Thanks.
So Yeah, you're right.
So that's a minus
and that's a plus.
Thanks.
So yeah, anybody has
a way to remember
whether it's inverse Fisher
information or Fisher
information as a variance
other than just learning it?
It is called information,
so it's really telling me
how much information I have.
So when a variance
increases, I'm
getting less and
less information,
and so this thing should
actually be 1 over a variance.
The notion of information is
1 over a notion of variance.
So now I just wrote this guy
like this, and the reason
why I did this is
because now everything
on the right-hand side does not
depend on any known parameter.
There's 0 and identity.
Those two things are
just absolute numbers
or absolute quantities,
which means that this thing--
I call this quantity here--
what was the name that I used?
Started with a "p."
Pivotal.
So this is a pivotal
quantity, meaning
that its distribution, at
least asymptotic distribution,
does not depend on
any unknown parameter.
Moreover, it is
indeed a statistic,
because I can
actually compute it.
I know theta 0 and I
know theta hat mle.
One thing that I did,
and you should actually
complain about this,
is on the board
I actually used i of theta not.
And on the slides, it
says i of theta hat.
And it's exactly the same
thing that we did before.
Do I want to use the
variance as a way for me
to check whether I'm under
the right assumption or not?
Or do I actually want
to leave that part
and just plug in the theta
hat mle, which should
go to the true one eventually?
Or do I actually want to
just plug in the theta 0?
So this is exactly
playing the same role
as whether I wanted to
see square root of Xn bar
1 minus Xn bar in the
denominator of my test
statistic for p, or if I wanted
to see square root of 0.5,
1 minus 0.5 when I was
testing if p was equal to 0.5.
So this is really a choice
that's left up to you,
and that's something you
can really choose the two.
And as we said, maybe this
guy is slightly more precise,
but it's not going
to extend to the case
where theta 0 is not reduced
to one single number.
Any questions?
So now we have our pivotal
distribution, so from there
this is going to be
my test statistic.
I'm going to use this
as a test statistic
and declare that if
this thing is too large,
n absolute value--
because this is really a way to
quantify how far theta hat is
from theta 0.
And since theta hat should be
close to the true one, when
this thing is large
in absolute value,
it means that the true theta
should be far from theta 0.
So this is my new
test statistic.
Now, I said it should be
far, but this is a vector.
So if I want a vector to be
far, two vectors to be far,
I measure their norm.
And so I'm going to form the
Euclidean norm of this guy.
So if I look at the
Euclidean norm of n--
and Euclidean norm
is the one you know--
I'm going to take its square.
Let me now put a 2 here.
So that's just the
Euclidean norm,
and so the norm of vector
x is just x transpose x.
In the slides, the transpose
is denoted by prime.
Wow, that's hard to say.
Put prime in quotes.
That's a statistic
standard that people do.
They put prime for transpose.
Everybody knows what
the transpose is?
So I just make it flat
and I do it like this,
and then that means
that's actually
equal to the sum of the
coordinates Xi squared.
And that's what you know.
But here, I'm just writing
it in terms of vectors.
And so when I run to write
this, this is equivalent,
this is equal to--
well, the square root of n is
going to pick up the square.
So I get square root of
n times square root of n.
So this guy is just 1/2.
So 1/2 times 1/2 is
going to give me 1,
and so I get theta
hat mle minus theta.
And then I have e of theta not.
And then I get theta
hat mle minus theta not.
And so by definition, I'm
going to say that this
is my test statistic Tn.
And now I'm going to have a test
that rejects if Tn is large,
because Tn is really measuring
the distance between theta hat
and theta 0.
So my test now is going
to be psi, which rejects.
So it says 1 if Tn is larger
than some threshold T.
And how do I pick this T?
Well, by controlling
my type I error--
sorry, the c by controlling
my type I error.
So to choose c, what
we have to check
is that p under theta not--
so here it's theta not--
that I reject so that
psi is equal to 1.
I want this to be
equal to alpha, right?
That's how I maximize
my type I error
under the budget that's actually
given to me, which is alpha.
So that's actually equivalent
to checking whether p not of Tn
is larger than c.
And so if I want to find
the c, all I need to know
is what is the
distribution of Tn when
theta is equal to theta not?
Whatever this distribution is--
maybe it has some weird density
like this--
whatever this
distribution is, I'm
just going to be able
to pick this number,
and I'm going to take this
quintile alpha, here alpha,
and I'm going to reject
if I'm larger than alpha--
whatever this guy is.
So to be able to do
that, I need to know
what is the distribution of Tn
when theta is equal to theta 0.
What is this distribution?
What is Tn?
It's the norm squared
of this vector.
What is this vector?
What is the asymptotic
distribution of this vector?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
Just look one board up.
What is this
asymptotic distribution
of the vector for which we're
taking the norm squared?
It's right here.
It's a standard
Gaussian multivariate.
So when I look at
the norm squared--
so if z is a standard
Gaussian multivariate,
then the norm of z squared, by
definition of the norm squared,
is the sum of the Zi squared.
That's just the
definition of the norm.
But what is this distribution?
AUDIENCE: Chi-squared.
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
That's a chi-square,
because those guys
are all of variance 1.
That's what the
diagonal tells me--
only ones.
And they're independent because
they have all these zeros
outside of the diagonal.
So really, this follows some
chi-squared distribution.
How many degrees of freedom?
Well, the number of
them that I sell, d.
So now I have found
the distribution of Tn
under this guy.
And that's true because
this is true under h0.
If I was not under
h0, again, I would
need to take another guy here.
How did I use the fact that
theta is equal to theta 0
when I centered by theta 0?
And that was very important.
So now what I know is that
this is really equal--
why did I put 0 here?
So this here is actually equal.
So in the end, I need c
such that the probability--
and here I'm not going
to put a theta 0.
I'm just talking
about the possibility
of the random variable that
I'm going to put in there.
It's a chi-square with d
degrees of freedom [INAUDIBLE]
is equal to alpha.
I just replaced the
fact that this guy, Tn,
under the distribution
was just a chi-square.
And this distribution
here is just
really referring to the
distribution of a chi-square.
There's no parameters here.
And now, that means that I look
at my chi-square distribution.
It sort of looks like this.
And I'm going to
pick some alpha here,
and I need to read
this number q alpha.
And so here what I need to do
is to pick this q alpha here,
for c.
So take c to be q alpha, the
quintile of order 1 minus
alpha of a chi-squared
distribution
with this d degree of freedom.
And why do I say 1 minus alpha?
Because again, the
quintiles are usually
referring to the area that's
to the left of them by--
well, actually, it's
by a convention.
However, in statistics, we
only care about the right tail
usually, so it's not
very convenient for us.
And that's why
rather than calling
this guy s sub 1 minus alpha all
the time, I write it q alpha.
So now you have
this q alpha, which
is the 1 minus alpha quintile,
or quintile of order 1 minus
alpha of chi squared d.
And so now I need
to use a table.
For each d, this thing is going
to take a different value,
and this is why I can not
just spit out a number to you
like I spit out 1.96.
Because if I were
able to do that,
that would mean that
I would remember
an entire column of this table
for each possible value of d,
and that I just don't know.
So you need just
to look at tables,
and this is what
it will tell you.
Often software
will do that, too.
You don't have to
search through tables.
And so just as a remark is
that this test, Wald's test,
is also valid when I have
this sort of other alternative
that I could see quite a lot--
if I actually have what's
called a one-sided alternative.
By the way, this is
called Wald's test--
so taking Tn to be this thing.
So this is Wald's test.
Abraham Wald was a
famous statistician
in the early 20th century,
who actually was at Columbia
for quite some time.
And that was
actually at the time
where statistics were getting
very popular in India,
so he was actually
traveling all over India
in some dinky planes.
And one of them crashed,
and that's how he died--
pretty young.
But actually, there's a
huge school of statistics
now in India thanks to him.
There's the Indian
Statistical Institute,
which is actually
a pretty big thing
and trans the best
statisticians.
So this is called Wald's
test, and it's actually
a pretty popular test.
Let's just look back a second.
So you can do the
other alternatives,
as I said, and for
the other alternatives
you can actually do this
trick where you put theta 0 as
well, as long as you
take the theta 0 that's
the closest to the alternative.
You just basically take the
one that's the least favorable
to you--
the alternative, I mean.
So what is this thing doing?
If you did not know anything
about statistics and I told
you here's a vector--
that's the mle
vector, theta hat mle.
So let's say this theta hat
mle takes the values, say--
so let's say theta hat mle takes
values, say, 1.2, 0.9, and 2.1.
And then testing h0, theta is
equal to 1, 1, 2, versus theta
is not equal to the same number.
That's what I'm testing.
So you compute this
thing and you find this.
If you don't know
any statistics,
what are you going to do?
You're just going to check
if this guy goes to that guy,
and probably what you're going
to do is compute something that
looks like the norm squared
between those guys-- so
the sum.
So you're going to do
1.2 minus 1 squared
plus 0.9 minus 1 squared
plus 2.1 minus 2 squared
and check if this
number is large or not.
Maybe you are going to apply
some stats to try to understand
how those things are,
but this is basically
what you are going
to want to do.
What Wald's test
is telling you is
that this average is actually
not what you should be doing.
It's telling you that
you should have some sort
of a weighted average.
Actually, it would
be a weighted average
if I was guaranteed that
my Fisher information
matrix was diagonal.
If my Fisher information
matrix is diagonal,
looking at this
number minus this guy,
transpose i, and then
this guy minus this,
that would look like I have some
weight here, some weight here,
and some weight here.
Sorry, that's only three.
So if it has non-zero numbers
on all of its nine entries,
then what I'm going to
see is weird cross-terms.
If I look at some vector
pre-multiplying this thing
and post-multiplying
this thing--
so if I look at something
that looks like this,
x transpose i of theta
not, x transpose--
think of x as being theta
hat mle minus theta--
so if I look at what
this guy looks like,
it's basically a sum over i and
j of Xi, Xj, i, theta not Ij.
And so if none of
those things are 0,
you're not going to see a sum
of three terms that are squares,
but you're going to see a
sum of nine cross-products.
And it's just weird.
This is not something standard.
So what is Wald's
test doing for you?
Well, it's saying,
I'm actually going
to look at all the
directions all at once.
Some of those
directions are going
to have more or less variance,
i.e., less or more information.
And so for those
guys, I'm actually
going to use a different weight.
So what you're really
doing is putting a weight
on all directions of
the space at once.
So what this Wald's
test is doing--
by squeezing in the
Fisher information matrix,
it's placing your problem
into the right geometry.
It's a geometry that's distorted
and where balls become ellipses
that are distorted
in some directions
and shrunk in
others, or depending
on if you have more variance
or less variance in those
directions.
Those directions
don't have to be
aligned with the axes of
your coordinate system.
And if they were,
then that would
mean you would have a
diagonal information matrix,
but they might not be.
And so there's this weird
geometry that shows up.
There is actually
an entire field,
admittedly a bit
dormant these days,
that's called
information geometry,
and it's really doing
differential geometry
on spaces that are defined by
Fisher information matrices.
And so you can do
some pretty hardcore--
something that I
certainly cannot do--
differential geometry , just by
playing around with statistical
models and trying to understand
with the geometry of those
models are.
What does it mean
for two points to be
close in some curved space?
So that's basically the idea.
So this thing is basically
curving your space.
So again, I always
feel satisfied
when my estimator
on my test does not
involve just
computing an average
and checking if it's big or not.
And that's not what
we're doing here.
We know that this theta hat
mle can be complicated--
CF problem set, too, I believe.
And we know that this Fisher
information matrix can also
be pretty complicated.
So here, your test is not
going to be trivial at all,
and that requires understanding
the mathematics behind it.
I mean, it all built
upon this theorem
that I just erased,
I believe, which
was that this guy
here inside this norm
was actually converging
to some standard Gaussian.
So there's another test
that you can actually use.
So Wald's test is one option,
and there's another option.
And just like maximum
likelihood estimation and method
of moments would sometimes
agree and sometimes disagree,
those guys are going to
sometimes agree and sometimes
disagree.
And this test is called
the likelihood ratio test.
So let's parse those words--
"likelihood," "ratio," "test."
So at some point,
I'm going to have
to take the likelihood
of something divided
by the likelihood of some other
thing and then work with this.
And this test is just
saying the following.
Here's the simplest
principle you can think of.
You're going to
have to understand
the notion of likelihood in
the context of statistics.
You just have to understand
the meaning of the word
"likelihood."
This test is just saying
if I want to test h0,
theta is equal to theta 0,
versus theta is equal to theta
1, all I have to look at is
whether theta 0 is more or less
likely than theta 1.
And I have an exact
number that spits out.
Given a theta 0 or a
theta 1 and given data,
I can put in this function
called the likelihood,
and they tell me exactly
how likely those things are.
And so all I have to
check is whether one
is more likely than the
other, and so what I can do
is form the likelihood
of theta, say,
1 divided by the
likelihood of theta 0
and check if this
thing is larger than 1.
That would mean that this guy
is more likely than that guy.
That's a natural way to proceed.
Now, there's one
caveat here, which
is that when I do
hypothesis testing
and I have this asymmetry
between h0 and h1,
I still need to be
able to control what
my probably of type I error is.
And here I basically
have no knob.
This is something if you
give me data in theta 0
and theta 1 I can compute to you
and spit out the yes/no answer.
But I have no way of controlling
the type II and type I error,
so what we do is that we
replace this 1 by some number c.
And then we calibrate
c in such a way
that the type I error is
exactly at level alpha.
So for example, if
I want to make sure
that my type I error is
always 0, all I have to do
is to say that this
guy is actually never
more likely than that
guy, meaning never reject.
And so if I let
c go to infinity,
then this is actually
going to make
my type I error go to zero.
But if I let c go to
negative infinity,
then I'm always
going to conclude
that h1 is the right one.
So I have this
straight off, and I
can turn this knob by
changing the values of c
and get different results.
And I'm going to be interested
in the one that maximizes
my chances of rejecting the
null hypothesis while staying
under my alpha budget
of type I error.
So this is nice when I have
two very simple hypotheses,
but to be fair, we've
actually not seen
any tests that correspond
to real-life example.
Where theta 0 was of the
form am I equal to, say, 0.5
or am I equal to
0.41, we actually
sort of suspected
that if somebody
asked you to perform
this test, they've
sort of seen the data before
and they're sort of cheating.
So it's typically
something am I equal to 0.5
or not equal to 0.5
or am I equal to 0.5
or larger than 0.5.
But it's very rare that you
actually get only two points
to test--
am I this guy or that guy?
Now, I could go on.
There's actually a nice
mathematical theory,
something called the
Neyman-Pearson lemma
that actually tells me that
this test, the likelihood ratio
test, is the test, given the
constraint of type I error,
that will have the
smallest type II error.
So this is the ultimate test.
No one should ever use
anything different.
And we could go on and
do this, but in a way,
it's completely irrelevant to
practice because you will never
encounter such tests.
And I actually find students
that they took my class
as sophomores and then they're
still around a couple of years
later and they're
doing, and they're like,
I have this testing problem and
I want to use likelihood ratio
test, the Neyman-Pearson one,
but I just can't because it
just never occurs.
This just does not happen.
So here, rather than
going into details,
let's just look at what
building on this principle
we can actually make
a test that will work.
So now, for
simplicity, I'm going
to assume that my
alternatives-- so now, I still
have a d dimensional
vector theta.
And what I'm going to assume
is that the null hypothesis
is actually only testing if
the last coefficients from r
plus 1 to d are fixed numbers.
So in this example, where
I have theta was equal--
so if I have d equals
3, here's an example.
h0 is theta 2 equals 1,
and theta 3 equals 2.
That's my h0, but I
say I don't actually
care about what theta
1 is going to be.
So that's my null hypothesis.
I'm not going to specify right
now what the alternative is.
That's what the null is.
And in particular, this null
is actually not of this form.
It's not restricting
it to one point.
It's actually restricting it to
an infinite amount of points.
Those are all the vectors
of the form theta 1 1,
2 for all theta 1 in, say, r.
That's a lot of vectors,
and so it's certainly
not like it's equal to
one specific vector.
So now, what I'm going
to do is I'm actually
going to look at the maximum
likelihood estimator,
and I'm going to say, well, the
maximum likelihood estimator,
regardless of anything, is
going to be close to. reality.
Now, if you actually
tell me ahead of time
that the true parameter
is of this form,
I'm not going to maximize over
all three coordinates of theta.
I'm just going to say,
well, I might as well just
set the second one to
1, the third one to 2,
and just optimize for this guy.
So effectively, you can
say if you're telling me
that this is the
reality, I can compute
a constrained maximum
likelihood estimator
which is constrained to look
like what you think reality is.
So this is what the maximum
likelihood estimator is.
That's the one that's
maximizing, say,
here the log likelihood over
the entire space of candidate
vectors, of
candidate parameters.
But this partial one, this
is the constraint mle.
That's the one that's actually
not maximizing our real thetas,
but only over the thetas
that are plausible
under the null hypothesis.
So in particular, if I look
at ln of this constraint thing
theta hat n c compared
to ln, theta hat--
let's say n mle, so
we know which one--
which one is bigger?
The first one is bigger.
So why?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET:
So the second one
is maximized over
a larger space.
Right.
So I have this all
of theta, which
are all the
parameters I can take,
and let's say theta
0 is this guy.
I'm maximizing a function
over all these things.
So if the true
maximum is this here,
then the two things are
equal, but if the maximum
is on this side, then
the one on the right
is actually going to be larger.
They're maximizing
over a bigger space,
so this guy has to be
less than this guy.
So maybe it's not easy to see.
So let's say that this is
theta and this is theta 0
and now I have a function.
The maximum over theta
0 is this guy here,
but the maximum over the
entire space is here.
So the maximum
over a larger space
has to be larger than the
maximum over a smaller space.
It can be equal, but the
one in the bigger space
can be even bigger.
However, if my
true theta actually
did belong to theta 0--
if h0 was true--
what would happen?
Well, if theta 0 is true,
then theta isn't theta 0,
and since the maximum likelihood
should be close to theta,
it should be the case that
those two things should
be pretty similar.
I should be in a case not
in this kind of thing,
but more in this
kind of position,
where the true maximum is
actually attained at theta 0.
And in this case,
they're actually
of the same size,
those two things.
If it's not true, then I'm
going to see a discrepancy
between the two guys.
So my test is going to be
built on this intuition
that if h0 is true, the values
of the likelihood at theta hat
mle and at the constraint mle
should be pretty much the same.
But if theta hat--
if it's not true, then
the likelihood of the mle
should be much larger
than the likelihood
of the constrained mle.
And this is exactly
what this test is doing.
So that's the
likelihood ratio test.
So rather than looking at
the ratio of the likelihoods,
we look at the difference
of the log likelihood, which
is really the same thing.
And there is some weird
normalization factor, too,
that shows up here.
And this is what we get.
So if I look at the
likelihood ratio test,
so it's looking at two
times ln of theta hat mle
minus ln of theta
hat mle constrained.
And this is actually
the test statistic.
So we've actually decided
that this statistic is what?
It's non-negative, right?
We've also decided
that it should
be close to zero if h0
is true and of course
then maybe far from
zero if h0 is not true.
So what should be the
natural test based on Tn?
Let me just check that it's--
well, it's already there.
So the natural test is something
that looks like indicator
that Tn is larger than c.
And you should say, well, again?
I mean, we just did that.
I mean, it is basically the
same thing that we just did.
Agreed?
But the Tn now is different.
The Tn is the difference
of log likelihoods,
whereas before the Tn was
this theta hat minus theta
not transpose identity of
Fisher information matrix theta
hat minus theta not.
And this, there's no
reason why this guy
should be of the same form.
Now, if I have a
Gaussian model, you
can check that those two things
are actually exactly the same.
But otherwise, they don't
have any reason to be.
And now, what's
happening is that
under some technical
conditions--
if h0 is true, now
what happens is
that if I want to calibrate
c, what I need to do
is to look at what is the
c such that this guy is
equal to alpha?
And that's for the distribution
of T under the knob.
But there's not only one.
The null hypothesis
here was actually
just the family of things.
It was not just one vector.
It was an entire
family of vectors,
just like in this example.
So if I want my type I
error to be constrained
over the entire space,
what I need to make sure of
is that the maximum
overall theta n theta not
is actually equal to alpha.
Agreed?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: So not equal.
In this case, it's
going to be not equal.
I mean, it can really
be anything you want.
It's just you're going to have
a different type II error.
I guess here we're sort
of stuck in a corner.
We built this T, and it has
to be small under the null.
And whatever not
the null is, we just
hope that it's
going to be large.
So even if I tell you
what the alternative is,
you're not going to change
anything about the procedure.
So here, q alpha-- so
what I need to know
is that if h0 is true,
then Tn in this case
actually converges to some
chi-square distribution.
And now here, the number
of degrees of freedom
is kind of weird.
But actually, what it should
tell you is, oh, finally, I
know when you call this
parameter degrees of freedom
rather than dimension
or just d parameter.
It's because here what we did
is we actually pinned down
everything, but r--
sorry, we pinned
down everything but r
coordinates of this thing.
And so now I'm actually
wondering why--
did I make a mistake here?
I think this should
be chi square
with r degrees of freedom.
Let me check and send
you an update about this,
because the number of
degrees of freedom,
if you talk to normal
people they will tell you
that here the number of
degrees of freedom is r.
This is what's allowed
to move, and that's
what's called
degrees of freedom.
The rest is pinned down
to being something.
So here, this chi-square
should be a chi-squared r.
And that's something you
just have to believe me.
Anybody guess what theorem
is going to tell me this?
In some cases, it's going
to be Cochran's theorem--
just something that tells
me that thing's [INAUDIBLE]..
Now, here, I use the
very specific form
of the null alternative.
And so for those
of you who are sort
of familiar with linear
algebra, what I did here is h0
consists in saying
that theta belongs
to an r dimensional
linear space.
It's actually here, the r
dimensional linear space
of vectors, that have the first
r coordinates that can move
and the last coordinates that
are fixed to some number.
Actually, it's undefined space
because it doesn't necessarily
go through zero.
And so I have this
defined space that
has dimension r, and if I were
to constrain it to any other r
dimensional space, that would
be exactly the same thing.
And so to do that, essentially
what you need to do is to say,
if I take any matrix that's say,
invertible-- let's call it u--
and then so h0 is going to be
something like of the form u
times theta and now I look only
at the coordinates r plus 1 2d,
then I want to fix those
guys to some numbers.
So I want to call them theta,
so let's call them tau.
So it's going to be tau r
plus 1, all the way to tau d.
So this is not part
of the requirements,
but just so you know,
it's really not a matter
of keeping only
some coordinates.
Really, what matters
is the dimension
in the sense of linear
subspaces of the problem,
and that's what determines what
your degrees of freedom are.
So now that we know what the
asymptotic distribution is
under the null, then
we know basically
that we know how which table we
need to pick our q alpha from.
And here, again, the table
is a chi-squared table,
but here, the number
of degrees of freedom
is this weird d minus r
degrees of freedom thing.
I just said it was r.
I'm just checking,
actually, if I'm--
it's r.
It's definitely r.
So here we've made tests.
We're testing if r parameter
theta was explicitly
in some set or not.
By explicitly, I mean we're
saying, is theta like this
or is theta not like this?
Is theta equal to
theta not or is theta
not equal to theta not?
Are the last
coordinates of theta
equal to those fixed
numbers, or are they not?
There was something I was
stating directly about theta.
But there's going to be some
instances where you actually
want to test something
about a function of theta,
not theta itself.
For example, is the difference
between the first coordinate
of theta and the second
coordinate of theta positive?
That's definitely something
you might want to test,
because maybe theta 1 is--
let me try to think
of some good example.
I don't know.
Maybe theta 1 is your drawing
accuracy with the right hand
and theta 2 is the drawing
accuracy with the left hand,
and I'm actually collecting
data on young children
to be able to test
early on whether they're
going to be left-handed or
right-handed, for example.
And so I want to just compare
those two with respect
to each other, but
I don't necessarily
need to know what the absolute
score for this handwriting
skills are.
So sometimes it's just
interesting to look
at the difference of
things or maybe the sum,
say the combined effect.
Maybe this is my two
measurements of blood pressure,
and I just want to talk about
the average blood pressure.
And so I can make a linear
combination of those two,
and so those things
implicitly depend on theta.
And so I can generically
encapsule them
in some test of the form
g of theta is equal to 0
versus g of theta
is not equal to 0.
And sometimes, in the first
test that we saw, g of theta
was just the identity or
maybe the identity minus 0.5.
If g of theta is
theta minus 0.5,
that's exactly what
we've been testing.
If g of theta is theta
minus 0.5 and theta
is p, the parameter of a coin,
this is exactly of this form.
So this is a simple
one, but then there's
more complicated
ones we can think of.
So how can I do this?
Well, let's just
follow a recipe.
So we traced back.
We were trying to build a test
statistic which was pivotal.
We wanted to have
this thing that
had nothing that depended
on the parameter,
and the only thing
we had for that
that we built in
our chi-square test
one is basically some form
of central limit theorem.
Maybe it's for the maximum
likelihood estimator.
Maybe it's for the
average, but it's basically
some form of asymptotic
normality of the estimator.
And that's what we started
from every single time.
So let's assume
that I have this,
and I'm going to
talk very abstractly.
Let's assume that I
start with an estimator.
Doesn't have to be the mle.
It doesn't have
to be the average,
but it's just something.
And I know that I have the
estimator such that this guy
converges in
distribution to some n0,
and I have some
covariance matrix theta.
Maybe it's not the
Fisher information.
Maybe that's something that's
not as good as the mle,
meaning that this
is going to give me
less information than the Fisher
information, less accuracy.
And now I can actually just say,
OK, if I know this about theta,
I can apply the multivariate
delta method, which tells me
that square root of n, g of
theta hat, minus g of theta
goes in distribution to some n0.
And then the price to
pay in one dimension
was multiplying the square
root of the derivative,
and we know that in multivariate
dimensions pre-multiplying
by the gradient,
post-multiplying
by the gradient.
So I'm going to write delta
g of theta transpose sigma--
sorry, not delta; nabla--
g of theta-- so gradient.
And here, I assume that
g takes values into rk.
That's what's written here.
g takes value from d to k,
but think of k as
being 1 for now.
So the gradient is really just
a vector and not a matrix.
That's your usual gradient
for real valid functions.
So effectively, if g takes
values in dimension 1,
what is the size of this matrix?
I only ask trivial questions.
Remember, that's
rule number one.
It's one by one, right?
And you can check it,
because on this side
those are just the
difference between numbers.
And it would be kind
of weird if they had
a covariance matrix at the end.
I mean, this is a random
variable, not a random vector.
So I know that
this thing happens.
And now, if I basically
divide by the square root
of this thing--
so for board I'm working with k
is equal to 1 divided by square
root of delta g of theta
transpose sigma delta nabla--
sorry, g of theta--
then this thing should go to
some standard normal random
variable, standard
normal distribution.
I just divided by square
root of the variance here,
which is the usual thing.
Now, if you do not have
a univariate thing,
you do the same
thing we did before,
which is 3 multiplied
by the covariance matrix
to the negative 1/2--
so before this role was
played by the inverse Fisher
information matrix.
That's why we ended up
having i of theta to the 1/2,
and now we just have this gamma,
which is just this function
that I wrote up there.
That could be potentially k by
k if g takes values into rk.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIPPE RIGOLLET: Yeah,
the gradient of a vector
is just the vector with all
the derivatives with respect
to each component, yes.
So you know the word vector
for derivatives, but not
for vectors?
I mean, the word gradient
you use for one-dimensional?
Yes, derivative
in one dimension.
Now, of course, here, you
notice there's something--
I actually have a
little caveat here.
I want this to have rank k.
I want this to be invertible.
I want this matrix
to be invertible.
Even for the Fisher
information matrix,
I sort of need it
to be invertible.
Even for the original
theorem, that
was part of my
technical condition,
just so that I could actually
write Fisher information matrix
inverse.
And so here, you can make
your life easy and just assume
that it's true all the time,
because I'm actually writing
in a fairly abstract way.
But in practice,
we're going to have
to check whether
this is going to be
true for specific distributions.
And we will see an
example towards the end
of the chapter, the
multinomial, where
it's actually not the case
that Fisher information
matrix exists.
The asymptotic covariance
matrix, is not invertible,
so it's not the inverse of
a Fisher information matrix.
Because to be the
inverse of someone,
you need to be
invertible yourself.
And so now what I can
do is apply Slutsky.
So here, what I needed to
have is theta, the true theta.
So what I can do is just
put some theta hat in there,
and so that's the gamma of
theta hat that I see there.
And if theta is true, then
g of theta is equal to 0.
That's what we assume.
That was our h0, was that under
h0 g of theta is equal to 0.
So the number I need
to plug in here,
I don't need to
replace theta here.
What I need to
replace here is 0.
Now let's go back to
what you were saying.
Here you could say, let
me try to replace 0 here,
but there is no such thing.
There is no g here.
It's only the gradient of g.
So this thing that says
replace theta by theta 0
wherever you see it
could not work here.
If g was invertible,
I could just
say that theta is equal to
g inverse of 0 in the null
and then I could
plug in that value.
But in general, it doesn't
have to be invertible.
And it might be a pain
to invert g, even.
I mean, it's not
clear how you can
invert all functions like that.
And so here you just go
with Slutsky, and you say,
OK, I'm just going to
put theta hat in there.
But this guy, I know I need to
check whether it's 0 or not.
Same recipe we did for theta,
except we do it for g of theta
now.
And now I have my
asymptotic thing.
I know this is a
pivotal distribution.
This might be a vector.
So rather than looking
at the matrix itself,
I'm going to actually
look at the norm--
rather than looking
at the vectors,
I'm going to look at
their square norm.
That gives me a
chi square, and I
reject when my test statistic,
which is the norm square,
exceeds the quintile
of a chi square--
same as before, just
doing on your own.
Before we part ways, I wanted
to just mention one thing, which
is look at this thing.
If g was of dimension 1, the
Euclidean norm in dimension 1
is just the absolute value
of the number, right?
Which means that when I am
actually computing this,
I'm looking at the square, so
it's the square of something.
So it means that this is
the square of a Gaussian.
And it's true that,
indeed, the chi
squared 1 is just the
square of a Gaussian.
Sure, this is the tautology,
but let's look at this test now.
This test was built using Wald's
theory and some pretty heavy
stuff.
But now if I start looking
at Tn and I think of it
as being just the absolute value
of this quantity over there,
squared, what I'm
really doing is
I'm looking at whether the
square of some Gaussian
exceeds the quintile of a chi
squared of 1 degree of freedom,
which means that this thing
is actually equivalent--
completely equivalent--
to the test.
So if k is equal to
1, this is completely
equivalent to looking at the
absolute value of something
and check whether it's
larger than, say, q over 2--
well, than q alpha--
well, that's q alpha over 2--
so that the probability
of this thing
is actually equal to alpha.
And that's exactly what
we've been doing before.
When we introduced tests
in the first place,
we just took absolute
values, said, well,
is the absolute value of
a Gaussian in the limit.
And so it's the same thing.
So this is actually
equivalent to the probability
that the norm squared is
larger so that the chi squared
of some normal--
and that's the q alpha
of some chi squared
with one degree of freedom.
Those are exactly
the two same tests.
So in one dimension,
those things just
collapse into being
one little thing,
and that's because there's
no geometry in one dimension.
It's just one dimension, whereas
if I'm in a higher dimension,
then things get distorted
and things can become weird.